رئيس مجموعه فاجنر بروجين يشتكي بين جثث
جنوده اين قذائف اللعينه رمضان قادر
وفزعيم الشيشاني مبتسما استطيع السيطره
على بخموت في ساعات اما وزير الدفاع
الروسي
المعدات العسكريه الجديده المرسله لجنوده
جبهه بوتين الداخليه ليست على ما يرام ليس
بسبب ما جرى فوق قبه الكريملين من هجوم
عسكري وانما لما يجري تحت القبه من صراع
على النفوذ او الولاء او الخلافه مساله
سوف تحسمها اخر امطار من جبهه بخموت يقف
عليها
خلفي تقع باخنوث التي تفصلنا عن السيطره
الكليه عليها مساحه لا تتعدى اثنين ونصف
كيلومتر مربع تقريبا سنسيطر على المدينه
بالرغم من افتقارنا للذخيره بخصوص العدو
فهو يفقد ما بين 4600 جندي يوميا وبما ان
المهمه الصعبه هنا تقوم بها فاجنر فالعدو
لا يقتصد في الذخيره والمدفعيه ولديه كميه
كبيره من المعدات الغربيه العصريه
والمسيرات اضافه الى انه مدرب بشكل جيد
ولذلك المعارك مستمره ليلا ونهارا وقواتنا
تتقدم الى الامام وباخمت الان تحولت الى
فاغنرلاند
اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بالتعمد افشال
قواته في باخموت وعدم امدادها بالذخيره
وهدد بالانسحاب من المدينه
اقتنص الفرصه رمضان قادروف لاثبات ولائه
لبوتين
كما تعلمون لقد راسلت القياده العليا
وعبرت عن استعدادنا لتولي زمام الامور في
بخموت والسيطره على ما تبقى من المدينه
بكل سرور اما بخصوص الكيلومترات القليله
المتبقيه فهذا غير صحيح الحقيقه ان فاجنر
سيطرت على اكثر من 90% من المدينه لكن
الجزء المتبقيه هو الاصعب والذي امامنا هو
معركه السيطره على المدينه التي تجري في
اخر جزء منها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وهيئه الاركان لم
ترد على تصريحات رئيس فاجنر لكن هناك من
قال ان على الشركات الخاصه تدبر امورها
بمالها وليس بامكانيات الدوله الرئيس
الروسي يصمت حتى الان اما لرغبته باستمرار
النزاع على الولاء له واما ان رؤوس حرابه
قد خرجت بالفعل عن السيطره
لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات